I'm always moving and shaking and
getting it done even in the midst of
craziness
always yeah yeah always and even when
it's not him he's doing it for somebody
else we had this uh we had this
great these three kids on that were
singing I can't remember what the name
of the group was but you signed the girl
oh yeah yeah the name of the group was
uh Pop Life uh initially and they were
she was the lead singer I remember peers
uh like was being mean and was like
we'll put you through but we're not
gonna put your band through and he's and
so and she was like no I'm staying with
my guys and they got I think they all
went all the way uh weren't they the
third place sons of the not the girl
Tony Tony yeah guys uh and then you know
they got to perform I think in the
finale with Stevie Wonder and everything
and she became who is she she became
keilani she's Kaylani yeah oh really
yeah I remember that I was on AGT as a
group called Pop Life yeah put a pop
life you can see Pop life so on AGT
yeah so I mean I got a lot of those type
of stories too of just like people when
they started and you know just being
there and but there are so many things
in life there this is it pop life you
want to play a little I don't know if we
can
play a little so he saw this girl and
you gave her sure a record deal first
record deals with your company yeah and
you launched her yeah Nick's Nick is
behind so many things that you don't
even know you know and that's what as
busy as he is
he's even busier you know that is true
but I love it man I mean like my my
vocation is my vacation I wake up each
and every day just and feel privileged
to be able to to get another shot at
making people this is Pop life this is
what he saw but look at kailani when she
was just watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
I can make some money here
all right just isn't that amazing that
he saw her I mean she's really talented
and it's adorable but that's not the
Kaylani we know that is not the kelani
we know but uh yeah you see it
[Music]